e
e e
you are
good evening
everyone I'll Now call to order this
meeting of Lancaster City Council for
January 28th 2025 a few reminders for
everybody at the top of the meeting this
meeting and all of its participants are
being recorded please take a moment to
silence your phones and devices if you
haven't done so already during this
meeting there will be several
opportunities for public comment anyone
making public comment should do so at
the microphone so you can be heard both
in the room room and on our live stream
comments should be related to issues
that have or may come before Council as
legislation and should be addressed
toward Council rather than other members
in the audience to keep time excuse me
um each speaker is given three minutes
to keep time we'll be using this light
that's in front of me here it will turn
green when a speaker begins turn yellow
when there is one minute remaining and
turn red when three minutes has been
exhausted I appreciate everyone's
efforts to make sure that everyone has
equal time this evening and now for all
of those who are willing and able please
rise for the Pledge of
Allegiance IED Al to the flag of the
United States of America and to the
Republic for which it stands one nation
under God indivisible with liberty and
justice for
all Mr Harris would you please call the
role of members yes Madam president Mr
Men here Mr Royo here Mr
GLE Miss Diaz here miss Greg Mr H here
and president Baker here councilors
Craig and colleages are excused this
evening we'll now move to our approval
of the minutes for the January 14th 2025
meeting of council motion to approve
second we have a motion and a second on
the meeting minutes are there any
Council comments on the minutes
hearing none Mr Harris Mr Men I Mr Royo
I miss Diaz hi Mr hirsh hi and president
Baker hi thank you we'll now move to
proclamations honors Awards and
resolutions of recognition our agenda
States we don't have any of those this
evening Mr Harris is that correct that
is correct Madam president thank you
we'll now move into our first public
comment period this is reserved for
residents who requested the opportunity
to address Council ahead of time again
uh speakers are limited to three minutes
and should give their name and block of
residents for a meeting record when they
begin Mr Harris has anyone registered
for this first public comment period
they have not Madam president thank you
right then we will move then to reports
requested by Council uh we have one of
those this evening um it is the witness
Stones project presentation um and I'm
pleased to welcome uh Dr Christina mcer
from historic Rockford and Pam Stoner
and others who will be presenting on the
project and Mr
polite uh as you approach there Mr F you
just make sure that light is on on the
microphone green light will be
there that I'll do you going to P up now
or later would you ask Mr Harris to do
it yes I think Mr Harris is queuing up
presentation members of council you also
have information in front of
you thank you
okay good good evening um Nelson polite
600 block of ucul Avenue lanaster
and um I am here tonight as uh president
of the africanamerican Historical
Society of south central
Pennsylvania and um I want to offer uh
these comments and
introduction uh on behalf of that
organization
um the witness
Stones um project is extremely
important um we we understand that um
this country has went through a period
of at least 250 years of the institution
of
enslavement and um what happened is uh
the those who were enslaved at that time
uh lost amongst many things their
dignity and their pride and
Humanity um so we're excited about
collaborating with this witness Stones
project because we realize that truth
brings
healing
um the historic
Rockford um Plantation was involved in
that institution of
slavery and
[Music]
uh this project helps right or
wrong
um we do this project
also understanding that it is extremely
important for us to involve our youth so
we connected with and partnered with um
the school district of
Lancaster uh to educate and to support
uh this
effort lastly uh have opportunity to to
introduce Pam Stoner she has been has
spearheaded this project for the last
couple of
years thank
you thank you so much for having us this
evening and thank you Nelson um as
Nelson said I am a representative of
historic Rock for I've been a volunteer
there for many many years and I can tell
you that uh in at least the last decade
we've been really working hard to tell a
more complete version of history as it
relates to General Edward hand and his
property uh several years ago we engaged
with the African-American Historical
Society uh to have assistance and how to
better tell the story of the enslaved
population that we uh that we know about
that are connected to our site um it's
been extremely helpful and one of the
ways that um we if you could switch the
slide one of the ways uh that we have
found that's Rock for you can go one
more sorry one of the ways that we have
found uh is is helpful is to um give a
physical presence to people who don't
have a voice in history or have not had
a voice in history and what you're
seeing here is one of the tools that
we've um initiated and that is an
exhibit that is in the center hall right
in front of the front door in the rock
for mansion and this is focused on a man
by the name of Frank he was a man of
African descent who was enslaved by
Edward H but who also self- emancipated
by escaping Rock Ford in 1802 and that's
how we know a few things about Frank and
we are able to tell his story we are
also aware of three other individuals
who were enslaved by the Han family they
were located at their home in downtown L
before they moved to Rockford their
house and you can switch
again wrong one sorry you can stay there
their house uh it was located um on the
Square in downtown Lancaster so when we
started to think about strategies for
memorializing and educating about those
individuals uh we we looked toward an
organization called the witness Stones
project they are located in Guilford
Connecticut their Regional nonprofit
that is dedicated ated to educating the
public about Northern slavery a topic
that a lot of people have don't know a
lot about and we experience that almost
every day when we do tours at Rockford
people are very
surprised um they help communities on a
local basis help to restore the history
of slavery and the humanity of the
enslaved people who lived in their
communities uh they work with um
organizations and communities all over
the Northeast in the Mid-Atlantic but
Lancaster is going to be their very
first project in Pennsylvania and it
looks like it's also going to be their
largest project to date so they're very
excited about this as as we are uh okay
so as you see in this slide we've got
some students uh at the heart of this
project is education as Nelson said
we're very happy that the school
district of Lancaster has agreed to be
our educational partner and that we have
Dr Todd mey Todd can you wave Dr Todd
mey an excellent social studies teacher
at masy who will be guiding his students
through this very difficult
information uh he has instructed them on
the five themes of slavery very uh
important foundation for this work and
now they are using primary source
documents to to research and look for
tidbits of information about the insl
aved people who are mentioned there it
helps them to connect with real people
by name who were enslaved in our
city uh they are also going to be
working on strategies to um connect with
the public on this they want to be able
to share their new knowledge uh it will
culminate with a dedication ceremony
that we are hoping to uh present this
spring we're working of course with the
city and a lot of other organizations
that need to coordinate on that so it
will be something that is well
publicized and uh as I mentioned open to
the public
um let's see here you can go to the next
slide okay so as I mentioned there will
be a a dedication ceremony so after
education and Civic engagement comes
memorialization as I mentioned before
it's really helpful if there is a
physical president presence for the
people we are trying to memorialize so
you can see here actual examples of
witness Stones two that are installed in
the brick uh in and I'm not sure which
city and also one uh that you can see
the scale it's a 4x4 in Block these are
going to be embedded in the ground in
the
surface um at the locations where
enslaved people lived and labored so you
can see here the Jasper Yates house
that's on South Queen Street and the
area that is um boxed with the red you
can see is uh the brick that that is
between the sidewalk and the street in
most areas throughout the historic
district uh that is where we expect
these to go we've been working with
representatives from the public works
department and city government to make
sure that we can navigate all the
logistics involved with um installing
these and we will be engaging a city
approved uh contractor to be able to do
this so that everything is is safe and
secure okay
okay uh as I mentioned the hand
household before Rock Ford was on the
Square in Lancaster and you can see see
two images here it was located around uh
the fountain and here's just a really
nice old photo of that same area that
may or may not show their home we're not
sure but the red dots that you see are
just a sampling of the locations where
witness stones may go we have a team of
local historians and researchers who are
work working um uh with uh in
consultation I should say with Dr LeRoy
Hopkins and they have gone through
hundreds and hundreds of documents to
find this
information
um we are gaining uh we are trying to
gain the support of of City residents
city um businesses and Property Owners
we certainly don't want to upset anyone
or cause anyone um heartache through
this process but uh it is our job to
encourage people to accept this as
history and as an important project for
our city we are really happy that Willow
Valley communities is on board they're
very enthusiastic in their support they
are of course the owners of the Jasper
Yates house and the uh future Mosaic
residences so that's a big feather in
our cap um okay you can switch
again okay uh this is a privately funded
project we have been really really
laying the groundwork for this for over
two years and we uh applied for and
received substantial Grant monies from
the County Community Foundation the
Steinman Foundation the art and Selma
Walters trust Willow Valley communities
private businesses and philanthropists
and just this morning we got word that
we received the entire request uh that
we put in to the high Foundation which
is also something that we're very very
excited about we're optimistic about
this project
um we think people will learn a lot from
it and we think that it it will go a
long way uh toward educating the public
about a subject that has sort of been
lost in time um we will continue to
raise funds for this and if we exceed
our goal we would like to be able to
extend this program we'd like to offer
it um to other nonprofits that may want
to be involved we would like to install
more witness Stones I did not mention uh
but I should that we are funding this
for three years and uh in each year
we're hoping to install 25 witness
stones in the historic district so um we
also as I mentioned want to extend the
project so that we can uh include more
students and with that I'm going to
introduce our masy student her name is
ariad ariadna and I would like to ask
you to come up to the
microphone thank you
hello my name is Arna Aila I'm a senior
at masi high school I'm involved in the
Budd Glover project where I have had the
opportunity to meet inspiring figures
like civil rights activist managing
Brown tricky and movie director Keith
buum after graduating I plan on
attending Dickinson College where I plan
to study political science and continue
to find ways to enrich the Lancaster
Community to me the witness zones
project will represent a way in which
the school will honor the people who
were part of a significant con
contribution to this
community and yet they were not
recognized because of the unjust system
set up by
Society while I participated in a summer
Pro uh program at Dickinson College
called knowledge for freedom I realized
how much history is not taught in
classrooms or really how much we don't
know about the history of the places
that we live
in furthermore I realized that there are
many Local Heroes that contributed to
something bigger in history and yet
they're often
forgotten I learned that through witness
Stones a lot of stories can be exposed
as a learning stop for all who see them
not only will it serve back to the
community by being a lesson to all who
see them but it will also honor the
families that never got the honor to be
recognized for their contributions to
Lancaster I speak for my classmates
involved in the witness Stones project
when I say how excited we are to perform
work that reconciliate with past
injustices
thank you for your support and with it
you will open opportunities for you and
many students who will follow to make a
lasting and positive impact on society
thank
you thank you so much to all of you um
who in the room is participating in the
project just out of curiosity there seem
to be a lot of folks here
thank you so much for for being here to
to tell us about where you're at and we
are really I I am very excited um about
this project and I think that living
history is so very important and and
hearing from you as a student in the
project is incredibly impactful and
exactly what I needed to hear today so
thank you um I'll take a moment if there
are any questions from members of
council that folks uh may be able to
answer this evening about the project
okay thank you very much for coming
before us tonight and if there's
anything that we can do to be of
assistance when it's time to put the
winess stones into the ground please let
us know all right thank you thank
you give us a moment to reset our
av and I will say we do have um an
agenda after this I know that some
people may be here just for that item so
I want to thank you
um and also you're welcome to stay if
you wish
Mr Harris are we good with the agenda on
the
screen may just need to
be that's
okay technology is not a perfect
technology thank you perfect all right
we will continue with our rest of our
agenda the next item is interum reports
of Committees of council which I don't
believe we have tonight Mr Harris is
that correct that is correct we do not
thank you we'll move into our
legislative agenda for this evening uh
our first items are historic district
items Mr Harris Mr M President we you
this evening considering the following
applications and recommendations from
the historical commission for
improvements to properties within the
Heritage Conservation District versus
Kenneth Dupri owner of 615 4th Street
freeer proposes demolition of a
one-story framed garage facing George
Street to allow new garage construction
on the site and kenth Dupri owner of
6154 Street rear proposed construction
of a new one-story frame garage facing
George
Street and Lancaster parking authority
owner of 111 North Prince Street
proposes expansion of recess ground
floor office space facing north FR
Street and new upper level wall
treatments and those applications were
all recommended for approval by the
historical
commission motion to approve second we
have a motion to approve and a second um
Council Royo just to clarifi it for each
item uh together is that correct correct
if I may Mr Mr H great thank you very
much uh thank you counselors uh in uh
councilor Craig's absence I'll just uh
make a comment each of you have received
memos from the historical commission
detailing their recommendations for
approval of these applications by
unanimous vote um if there are any
representatives for the applicants who
are here to wish to provide any
additional information you can come
forward at this time don't know that we
have
okay are there any additional comments
from members of Council on the
applications comments from members of
the public on the on the
applications hearing none Mr Harris Mr M
i Mr Roy i m
hi Mr her hi pres
I thank you we'll move into resolutions
uh we have one of those this evening
it's resolution number 8 2025 Mr Harris
a resolution extending Declaration of
the state of emergency related to
Emergency
Shelters motion to approve second we
have a motion and a second for the
resolution uh council members um I want
to thank you for this addition to our
meeting as you may recall we passed an
emergency declaration at the end of 2024
um so tenfold could operate a low
barrier shelter at their location on
East King Street this declaration was
set to expire on the 31st just a few
days from now um they have been
providing extended day shelter for
anchor during the code blue um and
continue to serve as an overnight
shelter during code blue um because of
this ongoing need tenfold has been in
touch with our uh the city planning team
to bring requests to zoning hearing
board uh in April for the permanent
zoning relief to allow this shelter to
continue to operate um this evening uh
we are requesting an extension of the
state of emergency so that the shelter
can continue to operate in our city and
I just want to thank tenfold for ramping
up their operations and continuing to do
this incredibly important work um in
temperatures that were um Subzero on
some nights in the in the recent uh days
um it's incredibly important that
they've been able to continue to provide
this
service any additional comments from
Council on the resolution to extend the
emergency uh council president I just
wanted to Echo the sentiments that we
thank our partners like tfold who have
been arm inarm with us as we fight this
homelessness uh crisis especially during
uh colder
temperatures mys thank
you comments from the public on the
resolution
darling bur andry how long are we
extending the emergency from it was to
go till April and now it's going to when
the original emergency declaration
covered through the 31st of January so
just the end of oh okay to the end of
January yeah so this is actually to
extend it um I'm going to get the exact
date through March 31st okay the plan is
to uh they're going to be able to come
before zoning and get the approval
before April oh okay so that it would be
a permanent shelter there then as of
before April the zoning would be for
would be in place for them to maintain a
shelter there without this emergency
declaration thank you absolutely any
additional comments from the public on
the
resolution hearing none Mr Harris Mr M i
Mr Roy i m Diaz I Mr h I pres B
I thank you that concludes our
legislative agenda this evening we'll
now move into our second public comment
period that's open for issues that were
not previously on the agenda again
duration of comments is limited to three
minutes per speaker please begin with
your name and block of residents for our
meeting record if there's anyone wishing
to make public comment this evening
please come forward at this time
darling bir I didn't get to speak
quickly about the project you didn't ask
for public comment but uh with the stone
um Foundation that just went on I hope
that we're looking at some way to
maintain it I heard them say three years
they would be funding and a lot of times
we see things put in our community to
represent our history and there's no
plan to upkeep them for 10 years from
now or the work that the students are
doing that Council would would at least
ask for what is your maintenance plan
what happens after 5 years I mean we
heard them say for 3 years but I think
that's important I do think it's a good
project but I think that maintaining
stuff that we put in our community is
also important and we need to figure out
how we're going to do that thank you
very
much any additional public comment this
evening
hearing none we'll close public comment
um the rest of the agenda uh the next
item is the report of the mayor mayor
sari could not be here this evening and
I don't have a report to give in her
place uh the next item is the report of
President of council I do not have a
specific report tonight um then so then
we will move to council comments are
there any Council comments this
evening right hearing none and having
reached the conclusion of our agenda
I'll hear a motion to adjourn motion to
adjourn second all in favor I I your
adjourn thank you